so as Matt mentioned hi everyone my name
is Valerie Karpov I currently work as a
kernel tools engineer for ma going to be
and I'm going to be talking to you guys
about the main stack and sort of provide
you a high-level introduction on what
the terms are that you should sort of
understand in order to get started with
developing with the mean stack so first
of all a little bit more about me I'm
not just some random guy on the internet
so i started my career as the CTO of
scavenger back in back when i was 19 as
a freshman in college yet that company
is now known as level up and is doing
quite well since then well since then i
also coined the term mean stack in a
blog post about a year ago my the the
blog post was based on my experiences
working for a couple of startups which
i'll talk about al in more detail a
little bit later but basically these
were sort of companies that came to me
asking me to build out a full stack
application for them and well i ended up
selling on the mean stack because I
thought or what would later become the
mean stack because it was really
freaking cool new technologies I wanted
to play around with them and to over the
course of my time working with them i
came across several aha moments where I
just realized man like web development
used to be hard before this to him so
yeah so let me talk a little bit more
about what the what the mean stack
actually is for those of you who just
aren't familiar with it just get
everyone on the same page so stands for
mongodb Express jazz angularjs and
nodejs now MongoDB is a document
database well what does that mean well
it seeks to sort of bridge the gap
between a document store like Redis and
a the richly featured SQL database so
you get sort of the simplicity and
elegance of storing objects as well as
the performance of a Redis type solution
with the with the rich features the
aggregation the incredibly complex
queries that you can do
with a MySQL or a postgres Express j/s
is a Sinatra based web framework on top
of nodejs that provides simple routing
features and the ability to sort of use
the use MVC like terminology on your
server with nodejs and angularjs
difficult to classify but it's a
client-side bottle view controller MV
whatever you want to call the
replacement for the seat at a high level
why it provides is the glue between your
server and your UI UX decisions and
nodejs what we're all here for event
driven i/o and javascript is the tag
line but that is sort of but that
doesn't quite capture the the depth of
functionality that you can do with the
vent driven IO in JavaScript so
hopefully i'll show you a few more
examples of cool things that you could
do with node so what is this talk going
to be about well I'm going to try to
convince you guys that you should build
your next web application whether it be
whether it be you know your next weekend
hack or something that you want to work
on for your job some task you want to
automate you should build that in the
mid stack that's what I think I thought
not necessarily good try to tell you to
convert your existing applications to
the mean stack not necessarily the right
choice but the so what we're going to
talk about is essentially what what
could go wrong and what could be
difficult with with building up a new
web application it should be easy but
often you run into you run into a lot of
these difficulties and as somebody who's
built more web tools that I can
reasonably counts I have some background
in this sort of thing and I'd like to
just share my experiences and help you
guys understand how the mean stack makes
solving these problems much easier
so the problem categories wouldn't
you're building a web application
generally looks something like this you
want what you're building a prototype
we've all had those projects that end up
getting mothballed after like six or
eight months of work because the finish
line doesn't seem to be getting in
anywhere closer adapting when you got
the product out the door but the clients
are collaborate for more functionality
the PM's wanted ad you just can't quite
figure out how to get that to fit within
the existing infrastructure testing
testing a web application is difficult
at a problem that hasn't quite been
solved to my satisfaction yet and well
it means that provides you with pretty
good testing tools for both n Ted and
your tests but we'll talk about that a
little bit later and finally scaling or
the best problem to ever have is people
are using your application so much that
you need to that you need to expand
across different machines or you need to
optimize your usage of a single machine
so i'll start off we'll have sections
for each of these and i'll highlight
sort of water to problems and stories
that i've had developing with the mean
stack or not mean stack related to that
particular issue and I'll start off each
one with a plug quotes keep things a
little bit fresh so when you want to
build out a prototype often you want to
remember the Facebook Developer mantra
done is better than perfect which very
accurate for facebook because their
product is very very far from perfect
but anyway so at some point the goal is
to get these to get a product into your
users heads as quickly as humanly
possible often that ends up being a
challenge and a lot of these tools were
actually built by people who wanted to
be able to ship products faster as a
matter of fact angularjs was actually
built by my mentor when I was it at
Google he built it about a year after my
summer internship and
there is white why he just built out
this tool was because he had a web UI
they wanted to build but again spent
about eight months on it wasn't getting
anywhere so he just decided to build a
framework to do it that did it in a week
and another another success story with
the mean stack and prototyping
effectively was the first startup that I
was working on when I was when I serve
when I was working on what became the
mean stack was I was a project called
the yeah Scott project it was a there
was a fun little fashion tech project
and we built it at a hackathon at Angel
hack in Washington DC in 2012 we
basically built the vast majority of the
product at a day released it the next
week and right wall right while the
investor interest was still hot and we
and we started making revenue from day
one so we went from not having a github
repo to revenue in about four days I
think like something to that effect and
so in terms of prototyping I think
that's about as not as good as we could
have reasonably hoped so what what about
the mean stack makes it possible to
build applications faster well of the
surface having one language makes things
easier just because you don't have to
necessarily parse things into what's
going to happen in one language versus
another your client is a JavaScript
you're not really good changed at a time
soon unless you develop the world's
coolest new web browser hopefully dart
will change that but we'll see you have
the you have your server written in
JavaScript and then your database
essentially stores JavaScript objects
and has a nice little JavaScript shell
that you can interact with so everything
is JavaScript and personally I love that
because I think javascript is a
conceptual language package management
so NPM is frickin awesome very excellent
tool there's also Bauer which is sort of
attached to NPM which does NPM like
functionality for the client side but
just not quite as well but a little bit
deeper than that is the bead stack sort
of minimizes the amount of glue code
that you need to
glue the data coming from your database
to your UI and that was what saved us so
much time so what does that look like so
angularjs gives you the ability to sort
of do what i like to call an interactive
client-side template now early days or
templates in rails or wherever you
wherever you develop your server side
MVC apps and basically server generates
that HTTP response that just contains
this block of HTML browser renders it
and then once it's shipped off does it
really change unless there's a little
bit of jQuery finagling with that dealer
that's kind of turned on its head and
the HTML was served up to the browser
with with all the templating language
already built in and then angular takes
care of binding all this data to the
appropriate places so essentially
angular takes care of the templating and
the advantage of that is well when
whenever your data changes on the
client-side do your client interaction
your date your UI updates to to reflect
that almost instantaneously without
having to reload the page now so what
this is what this is doing here is I
have a simple little to-do list
application that I will actually linked
to its on my github so I'm going to put
in a little bit of type in my type in my
you know task name gonna select the
dates and I'm going to selectively okay
go for it and again angular updates all
of this without me having to do any
actual work so there's the JSON object
that you see and that JSON object gets
shipped as is to the server the node.js
server gets exactly the same view of the
data except for it adds an underscore ID
field for for mongodb to track which
document this actually is and then
MongoDB gets you the data pretty much as
is with with minor will modification
with again the other score ID field so
now what is what does the was the
advantage to this well first of all
lower barrier to entry for new
developers again one language makes
things simple or one set of coding
convention
and one view of all of your data from
the database all the way up to your
client the declarative UX is also
extremely powerful the difficulty of
writing jQuery based javascript is that
a lot of your UX decisions start
floating off into magic old to a
separate javascript file and well I
don't know very many designers who are
good at right a good clean organized
JavaScript that they end up gay digging
themselves into a hole more often than
not and frankly even I do when writing
jQuery it's not terribly easy to write
it effectively so angular lets your HTML
or Jade or whichever templating language
you prefer be be your one true source of
all UI UX decisions and write that all
in a declarative syntax as opposed to
having to write imperative each loops
functional but whatever you want to call
it and ease your debugging when all data
looks the same it's fairly easy to see
oh ok there's ok the server got the
wrong data must have been the client and
to some limited extent you can reuse
code validation enums things like that
so that's why that's why prototyping is
super easy let's take a look a little
bit about adaptation which is fun
subject and we'll dig more into the node
side of things so a colleague of mine
over at MongoDB once likened launching
the first version of a product to start
to arriving at the starting line of a
marathon sure you take it like a two
hour bus ride suit gets the bill of
nowhere in Staten Island if you're
writing the New York Marathon but but I
made you you're just getting started so
as Eddie Van Halen once very
appropriately said you're just at the
beginning your application well your
prototype will be simple and elegant but
ideally if people are using its there
will always be somebody who wants one
more thing whether it be a product
manager business guy analytics guy
whatever so common tasks that I've seen
bring in somebody who wants to start
doing some intense number crunching on
your
on your data set and he can't deal with
anything that's not Excel so you have to
give a bit excelled up every day or
things like okay I want to be able to
store a separate notification after
everything after I fish serving up my
HTTP response to the user I just want to
ship off a notification that I did
something into my database or I want to
be able to do multiple HTTP requests in
parallel simple things that seems simple
but they get to be complex because of
locks and threads and concurrency being
a bit of a difficult thing so yeah as
you might've guessed threads and locks
are not very easy to work with and they
they cause a lot of opportunity for bugs
and they're difficult to test and
furthermore cron jobs are a pain in the
ass too they I if I had a dollar for
every time I got bitten by the bug where
cron jobs run under a different user I
will I would be a very rich man so but
on the other hand your server needs this
sort of concurrency you need to be able
to do multi-threaded things you need to
be dritten you need to do things that
are somewhat event-driven and you need
to be able to schedule things and no Jas
makes this extremely easy by virtue of
being event-driven there's no need to
set up a cron job when you can just set
a set timeout for how much time you need
or set a set interval and there's really
no need for there's really no need for
multi-threading what everything is
adventure of in any way and you can use
libraries like a sink to basically code
in all the logic that you need without a
single lock so here's a so best-case
scenario of what happens with with no
jsin sort of adapting with concurrency
me and my roommate a couple about a year
ago decided we start doing some Bitcoin
arbitrage back during that boom when
bitcoin went up from like 52 140 over
the course of a week that was fun time
but there were about like ten dollar
discrepancies
Queen different exchanges mouth Cox was
that 140 can't be X is that like 130 had
a nice little opportunity to make some
free cash but but well I had just quit
my job at a high-frequency trading firm
and I was rather terrified because of
the prospect of trying to build
something like this because I do people
with all numbers of PhDs and degrees and
more experience than I could ever
possibly hope to have in the trading
space spending months upon months trying
to churn out a a reasonable trading
system and well I had just spent the
last year and a half just working on you
know primarily market data feeds and it
was kind of depressing because I managed
to do by the job that I've been doing
for an hour debt for like the last year
and a half in about an hour because no
Jas made it just trivially easy I had a
had a socket i/o quiet pointing to a
screaming mount GOx mount gox's price
feed pinging a REST API every 15 seconds
on the other head combined these two
results see if they're sufficiently
different okay execute some trades and
with within an hour we were we were
actually live trading which just blew my
mind and then on top of that we wanted
to add a third exchange because we were
like oh this is really easy a been 50
bits later we had a third exchange of
doing some arbitrage there so made life
very easy so that's what so that's what
you could do with with node let's talk
about a little bit about testing and the
the discesa t2x actually execute your
code as Donald Knuth said again even
when code looks right it rarely actually
is so how you actually prove that your
code works it's a tricky proposition and
one that doesn't necessarily have the
right right answer in in what
development world especially when you
start shipping things or when you start
having interactive JavaScript on the
client side but what but one place where
we did something very well was that book
local which was the second startup that
I was working on with with
I mean stack application so we so we
launched our official products around
middle of August last year and it was
actually probably the most painless
launch I have ever seen in my entire
life I mean we're saying they're
expecting everything to just be
completely haywire and users to start
you know can play good blowing up but we
ran into one bug which we knew was
actually a bug and decided to release
anyway because we were hoping that would
rear its ugly head but everything else
just server just pretty much SAT there
for a week we pushed some we just kept
pushing code and everything just kept on
working and quiets pretty much more like
yeah okay everything's working fine for
the most part except for one person who
decided to call us because she thought
our login was broken it turns out she
was entering her full name as opposed to
her email even though the law gets set
to use your email but that's life and so
for and I credit the success of that
lodged primarily to our to our testing
abilities and sort of our fairly rigid
but not by any means perfect setup ave
unit tests event n test and in Suberu
and well not good service integration
yet but so if you were if you were
somebody who was just had it heard of
testing your code these are sort of like
some of the steps that you might go
through it's sort of coming to today's
conclusion of how to test your code so
we didn't so when you start thinking
about how to test your code maybe you
decide okay i'm just gonna like you know
test all everything manually i'm just
gonna you know just go through click on
things and make sure that it does the
right thing but that quickly spirals out
of control it's not productive to do
that for a general site how are you
going to test all Facebook's
functionality by pointing and clicking
but on the other hand you still need
this because well again your end user is
going to be a human they have to
actually use the site to and something
that's usable by machine not necessarily
usable by human you might start writing
unit tests which are great make sure
your code is well organized but they
don't catch the places where bugs always
happen which is in the interaction
between modules for the most part and
then tests are great
they test the entire suite of your site
through basically just automatic
automatic ly going to your home page
clicking on a few buttons making sure
things do what they should do but they
often require expensive set up and are
slow to run so you wouldn't want to have
to sit around waiting on the results to
two then go on to your next task test
runners can help you automate the the
setup process but don't solve the
problem of it being too damn slow and
taking up computing resources so
continuous integration where you run
your tests on every single commit across
every single browser is the current
answer to how that should actually work
is you commit your code and you do some
rudimentary tests before you commit but
when you push it it runs all the tests
through across your entire across your
entire every browser your support and
then you can very easily track well ok
this commit introduced this bug I know
what happened so how do you do this with
the how do you run through these tests
with the mean stack well very manual
testing no different unit testing on the
other hand JavaScript unit testing is
very easy very elegant might be slightly
controversial statement but such as life
all of that comes down to the fact that
dependency injection in javascript is
completely trivial angularjs is built in
dependency injection and while there are
count there are a fair number of
dependency injection modules for node I
wrote my own because none of the ones
did exactly what I wanted it's called
Omni di just look it up it stands for
one more node injector big fan of it and
highly recommend it but you could also
write your own it's more of a one
afternoon exercise as opposed to a sort
of you know one month exercise like it
might be in other languages for
end-to-end tests you have right now is a
library called angular dash scenario
might one angular or rather the angular
team is coming out with a replacement
called protractor but for now I'd your
scenario does a pretty good job of
what you want an end to end tests to do
in the web sites which is basically
hijack an iframe that points to your
that points to your homepage click on
some links make sure do tests like okay
click on this link make sure that make
sure you've navigated to this page and
for divs of this type of shown up and to
help automate the tester automate
end-to-end tests and you detest there's
a tool called karma to may have heard of
pretty freaking awesome it's a test
runner that essentially automates all of
these all these tests for you it can
launch browsers run your unit tests on
any any browsing once it's also tied
into tools like tools like node units
for nodejs you to test so you can hijack
phantom j/s and run it it used to be
test tacular yeah to be fair I do have I
do actually still have a code base that
that actually does still use testacular
but I actually do not understand why
they changed that name that was like my
favorite name of any tool ever yeah I
know but but it gave so so carbo was
originally called testacular
accommodative portmanteau of tests
that's spectacular but uh but of course
naturally they subtitled or they gave it
the caption the test runner with balls
and some people didn't jive well with
some people apparently so they changed
it to karma but yeah so it's compatible
with jasmine for quad side you to test
known you'd it for for server-side unit
tests and angular scenario for for your
end-to-end test so you can automate all
that setup and for continuous
integration I can't quite not going to
quite go into all that detail but but
karma integrates very easily with NEC I
of your choice Jay kids Travis semaphore
I haven't tried drone yet but I would
presume it would be pretty easy to
integrate with drone as well so that's
kind of all I have to say about
how testing works let's talk about
scalability which is fun subject right
for engineers skill villa is awesome
okay scale to 100 billion users and
beyond but well word of caution and
probably probably the side that you
don't want to read but but well
scalability is beyond a certain point is
mostly just a Maserati problem in the
sense that it when it's it's a problem
that's not really a problem when you
have it because well if you've gotten to
a stage where basically everybody in
your company or all of your target
audience is hammering your site at the
same time you've you've clearly done
something right and you probably have
our mountains of VCs or internal people
barging knocking down your door trying
to help you out with your with the
codebase are trying to throw money at
you so for the most part it's a problem
that you don't necessarily have to worry
about because the because the hardest
part of scaling an application to a big
a hundred or to hit having a hundred
billion users every day is building an
application that's so damn useful that
hundred billion people want to use it
every single day and if you want to read
a little bit more about that this link
which'll again this slide deck will be
up on SlideShare Twitter and the meetup
post is moderately not safe for work
it's entitled very very appropriately
I'm gonna scale by foot up your
expletive and it goes through a very
very crass but philosophically
interesting argument along these lines
so if you're interested in sort of
reading about more about that check that
post out it's awesome but the other the
other question that often gets wiped out
in the question of does does rails scale
or just mean stack scale or does blah
blah blah scale is scale to what but as
the as the previous was the article that
I linked to the previous slide would say
well saying that rails doesn't scale is
like complaining that your car does it
go infinitely fast no car goes
infinitely fast just like nothing is
going to scale to infinity but but the
question is how much do
how much load do you need to handle and
well difficult to judge the exact number
but if i had to guess at order magnitude
it would be like somewhere between a
thousand ten thousand unique users a day
obviously completely dependent on your
usage patterns and all these things but
mostly just a little bit to a single
bescheid and walk through sort of like
the the the very small set of mistakes
that every that every new web developer
almost every new web developer ends up
making so horror story from that was was
what I was working on scavenger the
precursor to level up our first big
event was back in two thousand eight and
I was 19 at the time I had no idea what
I was doing it I thought SQL queries all
took the same amount of time to execute
like a very smart person I was and what
ended up happening there was well in an
interesting design decision you had to
text starts to our servers in order to
start your text message-based scavenger
hunt so when we had a hunt of about
1,000 people they all texted start at
the same time and the server just tipped
over very very very unfortunate and I'll
walk you through sort of like at a high
level what happened there and what are
some of the other mistakes that I've
made in terms of scalability so the the
first the biggest key points overarching
whole web scalability is that so you've
heard this one before is don't be slow
Beal the painter now this is this is an
old Yiddish joke that was first
mentioned in the context of software by
the author of The Joy on software blog
joke goes something like this so
schlemiel decides that he's going to get
a job painting a road and and but every
day he decide he starts painting less
and less and less and his boss asks him
show me what's going on or are you
working too hard or maybe are you just
get lazy do you not like your job and
schlemiel says no just the pay cab keeps
getting further and further away so you
don't want to do that and how do you
avoid doing that well one big bed with
is like the most scarce thing that you
possibly have as a web developer and you
need to make sure that you use
it's as effectively as humanly possible
bandwidth to you from your server to
your user is very very scarce so one are
you asking the browser to cash assets
for as long as reasonably possible and
make then again are you been defying all
of your stuff well you could use grunt
to do that but with with bead stack n
nodejs in particular grunts uses a
javascript bit of fire called uglify jas
which is just an MPN module that's
floating around that you can plug into
your code so my preferred approach
actually involves without minifying on
the file system just have your server
minify your javascript on servers owner
doesn't take reasonably log and has a
couple of distinct advantages first
being that your server will crash if
your client side JavaScript has a syntax
error which is good because you don't
want your server to start and start
serving up garbage JavaScript to people
and second approach and second benefits
is that it um is that it loads or it
minified the JavaScript in memory and
serves it up from memory which as
conveniently is number two which is the
other really really scarce thing that
you don't want to deal with is is
reading from the hard drive hard drives
are slow extremely slow especially on
ec2 where they're basically just it's
not even an actual spitting disk drive
it's some weird network back drive that
is subject to some internal network
latencies now if you actually had a
spinning disk drive the order of
magnitude that you could expect for how
many reads that you could do from that
hard drive in a second is order of a
thousand which
sounds like a lot except for you know
when if somebody to load your homepage
they need to do and SQL join that takes
about that reads from the hard drive in
three distinct places and then also
loads up a couple images from your
server and then your actual HTML file
well that adds up to six requests right
there and that means you've only got
maybe like what 160 people who can
actually hit your site in a second which
is not bad but gets quickly worse the
more content that you add onto your site
so big key is your database reading from
the hard drive and well with MongoDB not
necessarily a problem or not that much
of a problem if you're if you're used to
MySQL world or postgresql world you'll
probably be using memcache G as a
cashing service in front of your
database not necessary we're not
strictly necessary with MongoDB because
MongoDB is very very aggressive with
with basically putting as much into
memory as it possibly can as a matter of
fact if your data doesn't fit in memory
mogul DB will actually take up all
available memory and well some people
think that's a problem but on the other
hand if you have wasted memory than
you're wasting performance and final
points of what choke the the scavenger
servers was was making sure that you
don't choke up the CPU now not
necessarily a problem with no jeaious
but if you're using Ruby and you have
some long-running read operation or an
HTTP request everything is backed up
behind it if your servers
single-threaded and obviously that's a
huge disaster what happened to us was
that well our rescue all queries were
going to be slow and backed up because
of the hard drive and that meant that
all other requests were backed up behind
it too and that ended up triggering a
bunch of timeouts overflowing some
things somewhere and making the server
tip over oh no Jess this isn't a problem
because everything is event driven so
everything can sort of proceed according
to plan and if it doesn't have to read
from the hard drive then it does
so that's that's all I have on the the
four topics of discussion but I'd like
to address like a mother little common
criticism or point that's made which is
people often ask well well these are
cool hip new technologies is that's
awesome but will they be obsolete in
five years and the answer is well
realistically I would actually kind of
hope so I would actually hope that sort
of there's something new that comes out
that replaces one or more of these tools
that does things better and well
fundamentally the question comes down to
what development is very pretty simple
thing we all we have a very simple
structure for it you have you send an
HTTP request to a server you get a
response back that includes some
JavaScript that adds some bells and
whistles to what you sent back but
realistically it's very straightforward
and all we're doing is sort of building
up these abstractions and tools to work
better with in this existing framework
and if something comes out that's better
by god I'd love to use it but for now I
think that the but there again
limitations that are sort of inherent in
this particular and the particular model
of HTTP requests HTTP response and
inherent into the structure of the
internet that sort of are covered that I
sort of covered in this particular talk
now and hopefully I've shown you guys
how you can sort of get through these
problems with the mean stack and how it
makes these problems a little bit more
manageable and make some web development
a little bit more fun so that's all I
have to say about that thank you thank
you guys very much for listening and
these slides will be up on the meetup
and all that so don't worry too much
about that but thank you guys very much
for listening it was very much pleasure